we want to invest in the children and
invest in our features however it's
impossible at the moment
in schools across the country it's
becoming increasingly difficult to make
the numbers add up we're in crisis every
school is in crisis cost of living is
going up cost of wages going up Energy
prices transport you name it it's going
up
it's the cost of everything has risen
schools are being forced to make cuts at
this primary near Stafford they've
reduced the number of teaching
assistants and increased some class
sizes to 32 children
morally it's not great uh we want to do
as much as we can to support children
their education the vulnerable children
are mostly affected it's heartbreaking
[Music]
[Applause]
problem is the vast majority of school
budgets go on staff wages so the only
way to make real savings is redundancies
this head teacher from another school
has had to make that decision already
she spoke to us anonymously because she
wants her staff to enjoy Christmas
before she tells them
we're going to have to cut three senior
teachers and some support staff as well
once these Cuts have been made the
standard of Education in my school will
not be good I feel sick and I feel
horrified for the families the community
that we serve I feel very very worried
about the future
she's far from alone a survey of more
than 11 000 School leaders in England
has found the majority will have to cut
staff next year two-thirds plan to lose
teaching Assistance or reduce their
hours while half are looking at cutting
teachers or teaching hours
me and we've got six but some staff are
leaving anyway teaching assistant Emma
Smith says she can no longer afford to
live on the 12 000 a year salary
I could go and work in a supermarket
stacking shelves for around that that
which obviously has got no
responsibility yeah I absolutely love my
job and I am I'm mortified that I'm
having to move on what happens next
unions are urging the government to
listen ahead of the Autumn statement
this month failing to increase budgets
would be catastrophic for young people
and if we really are going to repair the
damage of the current crisis we need to
invest in young people right now
but with warnings of public sector Cuts
teachers fear for the future of their
schools Becky Johnson Sky News Stafford